Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I'm
your host, David Flanagan,
also known across the Internet as Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at a
piece of open source tools to help simplify
and flexify words I've just made up here
Kubernetes deployments.
Today, I'm joined by the creator and maintainer,
Alexander.
Hey, man. How's it going?
Hi. Thanks for having me. I'm good. How
are you? Yeah. I'm doing very well. I'm
always excited to see a new tool in
the Kubernetes space, especially when I'm not entirely
sure how to pronounce the name. But today,
we're taking a look at Clue Control, Clue
CTL, Clue Cuddle, Clue Cuddle.
Anything else you wanna add there?
I would say just late into the hands
of the community. Don't know. All this, so
Clue CDL is fine. Clue Catalog is fine.
Everything is fine. Clue Control. Let's go with
that one. Alright. Yeah. Great. Could you please
take a before we start talking about Clue
Control, just take a moment to tell us
a little bit about you and what you've
been up to, please.
Yeah. My name is Alexander Block. You can
also call me Alex or Coda Block when
I'm online.
So same handle used on Twitter and GitHub.
I'm a senior
DevOps engineer,
back end developer,
software developer.
I'm a consultant, freelancer,
and I'm very
excited about open source development. So I'm trying
to do that whenever possible.
I'm trying to contribute whenever possible.
And
Kluctl or Kluctl
Kluctl control. Yeah. We we we started to
call it Kluctl.
It's kind of the first big project that
I started from scratch and which is kind
of my my own baby right now.
So yeah.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing.
Maybe you'd like to give us the quick
TLDR
of what Kluctl Control is. Now I know
we're gonna have some slides, so just give
us, the thirty second
kind of pitch. Like, what is Kluctluctl? What's
the history? Why why did you start building
this thing? Yeah.
I'd I'd describe it as the missing glue.
So that's where the name comes from, by
the way, Kluctl with k instead of g
and without the e.
So Clue, Glue, whatever.
It's the missing glue between tools that already
exist, for example, Helm and Customize, and it's
kind of a front end to these. It
allows you to define multi environment, multi cluster
deployments,
and it has a CLI to control these,
actually to do the deployments, to diffs and
dry runs and so on.
So, yeah, that's Clue Studio.
And in these slides, I will try to
explain
how
it came to that tool and what's the
reasons reasoning behind that is.
Alright. Without further ado, let's hand over to
your slides then. If you wanna get them
ready, I'll pop the scene over. And as
always, there are people watching, Please feel free
to add any questions that you have throughout
the session and to the chat and comment
box, and we will do our best to
tackle them.
Great. Alexander, your slides are now live. Take
it away.
Great. So I assume you can see the
Kluctl scale logo? We can indeed.
Great. So let's start. So just a small
agenda for the slides. I'll try to make
it as short as possible, so not so
much slides. The hands on is the most
important stuff that comes later. So who am
I?
Just why another tool introducing ClueCDL and then
the actual hands on.
I already explained why I am, so I
think I can skip it.
Let's go to why another tool.
So I've been working on many, many deployment
projects in the past. It started with plain
Docker, then Docker Compose came and Docker Swarm
and later Kubernetes.
And it turned out that every
one of these projects
had the same requirements and same problems to
be solved.
On the next slides, I'll try to give
an overview of these and describe
why existing tools did not solve them.
It won't be the focus, but I'll try
to do it kind of in between.
So
of course, one of the most important requirements
is infrastructure as code. So everything 100% must
be as code, meaning it should be part
of version control
and
yeah, so
that you don't have to type in
kubectl
all the time and recreate everything by hand.
I
prefer
declarative code whenever possible,
but there are still situations where imperative parts
are still needed. As an example,
having declared everything is good, but in the
end, you still need to adhere to
deployment order, for example. As an example, you
have to deploy a namespace before you can
deploy
any other object onto the namespace.
So that is kind of a mix of
decorative and imperative.
It must be fully automatable
and reproducible,
and for me, it was always important to
at least allow the coexistence of GitOps and
DevOps
in a seamless way. I'll explain that later
a little bit.
Another requirement is I always needed to have
to support multiple environments, so it's not enough
to just have a bunch of YAML files
and
just deploy them to one cluster, and
that's it. That's not enough.
We always have multiple environments. We have tests.
We have dev. We have production
and so on.
These are not necessarily on the same cluster.
They are actually quite often on different clusters.
So you have a prop cluster, have a
test cluster and so on.
It's,
at least in my opinion, should always be
the target to have as much parity as
possible between environments, so they should look like
the same or at least have the same
source
and shouldn't have that much differences.
In practice, that's not always the case because,
for example, if you deploy something on your
local machine, you will probably not deploy all
the monitoring stuff while you would deploy that
to prod.
Next requirement is
it's always required to have proper secrets management.
I prefer version controlled
encrypted secrets
with public key
encryption,
and it always turns out that there are
nice tools to do that. But the hard
part, which is key management and
actually encrypting the correct secrets with the correct
public key for the correct cluster is actually
the hard part of that.
So next thing is
deploying
some environment, for example, dev to a prop
cluster, by accident
should be impossible by design.
What I mean with that is if I,
as a DevOps engineer, want to deploy something
to dev, I should not first
I shouldn't have to figure out what context
to use. I shouldn't have to figure out
what other credentials are required. I shouldn't have
to figure out what configuration I should choose
to deploy to dev.
My deployment
should self define what dev is, so what
the environment dev is, what it means, which
cluster it is, what configuration, and so on.
That means environments must be a first class
concept. That's a requirement that I had for
myself all the time.
Next.
By the way,
if you have questions in between, just stop
me and ask them whenever you want to
or comments or whatever.
Also, when comments arise or something like that.
So the next topic, configuration management.
To meet the previously described requirements,
some form of configuration management must be possible
because environments differ in all kinds of variations.
There are simple variations. For example,
prod needs another database than dev, and
it gets more complicated when, for example, your
local deployment doesn't even use an external database
but wants to deploy its own database because
it doesn't have one externally available.
Yeah, and then there are other examples. For
example,
if you have a test environment, it might
be useful to
deploy a mail interceptor, something like mailhack or
mailhawk, I don't know what it's called, while
you never would like to deploy that to
prod.
So that gets a little bit more complicated
in regards to configuration management.
So in my opinion, templating is a must,
and I believe that overlays are not enough
to solve that. You can solve most of
that with overlays, for example, with customized overlays,
but it will get hard and feel unnatural
if it gets too complicated. At least that's
my personal
experience and opinion.
Next requirement I always had is I want
to move fast. I'm a very impatient DevOps
engineer.
Stuff must happen immediately,
and I must be able to change stuff
as fast as possible
with the security
or the confidence that what I do actually
results in what I want to do.
For that, I need a proper logical project
structure that
feels natural.
What that means is
so if I open my project in two
weeks after I close it today, I must
be able to immediately understand it because it's
kind of natural to the way I
think and how I structure my stuff.
If, for example, something's based on customize and
overlays, I often got to the point where
it didn't feel natural anymore,
and understanding my own stuff was very hard
after some time
because that's not how I think.
Yeah. Boilerplate that doesn't add value should not
be present at all. At least that's what
I believe.
If I just want to add one YAML
file and just one resource
and that's all I want to do, it's
I don't like to add too much boilerplate
to just do that. For example, adding a
Helm chart just
to add a small module that adds one
YAML is
too much, at least in my opinion.
Without the requirements met from above, refactoring and
high risk changes are no fun,
which usually leads to not doing refactoring and
not doing high risk changes or at least
postponing them forever.
Then I'd like to avoid push and pray
workflows as much as possible. So when I
remember my first days as a DevOps engineer,
one thing that was the most,
yeah, not fun part was to do a
change, commit it, push it and wait for
Jenkins,
GitLab, whatever to finish a pipeline.
And just after
a few minutes knowing that my change was
actually broken and then redoing the same workflow
again and again and again.
So that means I want to develop locally
and I want to test locally,
And I mean everything. So I must be
able to completely verify locally that my deployment
will actually work no matter how simple it
is, no matter how complex it is, no
matter how small or large my change was.
Based on that, day two operations should be
supported in some way or at least made
easier.
That means I must always be able to
determine the current state of my deployments, so
not just look at Git, for example,
and see, okay, that's the state how it's
defined. I must also be able to verify
that this is really the state of the
cluster.
GitOps kind of allows that, but not in
all cases.
And if you want to mix DevOps with
GitOps, then you need other ways as well.
Next thing is I must always be able
to predict what consequences my changes will have.
That means if I change a helm value,
for example,
I must know what consequences that change has.
Just looking at the changes in git will
just tell me, for example, that one value
has changed.
But the templating behind helm might result in
very big structural changes of whatever I deploy,
And I must have a way to actually
see these changes, for example, by having a
dry run being applied and then seeing the
logical diff or the structural diff.
Then I must always be able to
determine what consequences my changes actually had. So
even if I
assume that this will happen, I must later
be able to verify that it happened.
That means I want this, this, this, and
much more this and not just keep this.
So basically, that means what I just explained.
A change in a HIM value does not
reflect what really will happen. I want to
have a full
diff of the state
before and after my change.
Yeah. If these requirements are met, I think
that DevOps or the daily business as a
DevOps engineer becomes a breeze
because you get into a point where
a change
doesn't
make you
paranoid
or cause fear and
kind of
make you avoid doing changes to plot or
something like that.
Yeah. Opening the gates to hell.
All the available tools on their own
were not able to solve all these requirements
in the last few years.
It was always required to do some kind
of deployment orchestration
or glue code, as I call it.
It and from my experience, it always starts
like, it's just a few lines of bash.
Let's start with the deploy.sh,
tell it which
environment to deploy it to, and then we
are happy.
I'd say a %,
you'll wake up in hell after some time.
So at least use Python
or maybe a dedicated tool that solves all
this.
Yeah. So next next one is actually introduce
you closely. Do you have any questions or
comments so far?
I would say that based on what you've
described,
clear control is promising a lot, and I'm
quite excited to what we're we're gonna see
in this definition. Like, you've touched on a
lot of really valid concerns,
like Yeah. You know, especially the helm one
resonates well with me. I've been in that
position before where you make what you think
of it as a professional change to the
values dot YAML, and then you end up
destroying the entire deployment in a production environment
or maybe even not production, but still an
important environment because prod isn't the only one
that important. Yeah.
In the end, every environment is important because
if it causes you extra work to fix
what you just broke,
I mean, you've you've lost time that you
could have spent in different ways. But I
don't QA. It could be staging. It could
be performance. It could be p prod. Like,
all of these environments need care and attention.
And, yeah, I don't like being the one
to break it. So and I've done it
before with a helm values thing. It's something,
again, trivial. I'll just change this one parameter,
but actually, the repercussions of that lie deep
and cascade down all the other deployments. So
Yeah. I'm excited to see what Kluctl control
is gonna bring to kinda bring that under
management.
Yeah. So no questions right now, but a
lot of excitement.
That sounds good. That's a good start. Maybe
to to get more to that point with
with Helm.
So when you have when you are using
Helm and, like, you're using a lot of
Helm charts, you, of course, have to maintain
the used Helm charts in the form of
doing updates and pulling in changes or new
versions and stuff like that.
And
so
without proper tooling, you are kind of blind.
You see, oh, there's a new Redis release.
Let's pull it and deploy it, and we
are happy. The problem is, Redis is good
example, at some point, they changed,
I think, slave to replicas in the
deployment mode,
which meant that your existing configuration
was invalid
because you are still you were still using
the old naming for the deployment mode,
which would completely break your deployment without you
having changed any of your configuration.
So what you actually need is
you need a way to
dry run or do a diff
for the changes that you just did or
if you do helm updates and stuff like
that. So I can say that
the projects where Kluctl is in use, we
have no problem with helm updates at all.
We do it once a week. We go
through all the projects
and
update dozens of helm charts every single week.
And we are completely confident that it will
not break stuff because
if it will break stuff, we will know
it before it breaks stuff because we just
see it.
Yeah. There's a cool it's a slight segue,
but just because we're talking about helm and
changes, it's like one of the challenges is
that when you pick up a new version
of a helm chart, you really don't know
what's changed, and you don't know what's changed
to the templating. You don't know what's changed
in the schema for the values fail. Although
they are Yep. Trying to make improvements there.
And something I think is really cool that
we should take away from the JavaScript ecosystem.
And maybe something that Kluctl does, and I'm
just I don't know. Maybe I'm heading on
it. But is the ability to do snapshot
style testing where you actually take the render
to YAML and then validate that on every
subsequent deploy? Because quite often when we do
upgrades, we don't really expect the template to
YAML to change much. And if we do,
we need to know.
So yeah. Maybe it may hopefully, that's something
that Kluctl's going to do. Yeah. It does
it does on multiple levels.
So one level is the Helm integration assumes
that you pre pull
Helm charts and actually put them into your
version control. This has different reasons, which I
will explain later in the hands on. But
one side effect of that is if you
do that, you see in the GitDiffs or
in the merge request that you later do
to actually merge in the upgrade what has
changed.
If you want to, you can then
go deep into the Helm changes and verify
that nothing strange is happening.
Or then the next level applies. If you
do the deployment, Closedale will always do a
dry run before it actually does the deployment.
So it will tell you
line by line
what has changed.
So if, for example, you have a Helm
chart that changes hundreds of lines of templates,
but it's just refactoring because it changed some
naming or something like that, looking into Git
would be not so fun because you would
see a lot of changes that actually have
no effect.
But when you later do the occlusal d
l diff or deploy, you will see that
nothing has changed and you can be confident
that deploying that to whatever environment you want
wouldn't do any harm.
So Right. I said multiple
levels.
Yeah. So
where I'm right now okay. Introducing.
So after multiple incarnations of such scripts, so
it always started like a deploy. Sh and
first parameter was the environment name, and then
internally, it knew what to do, which hand
charts to deploy and which environment needs to
do stuff differently, when to wait on stuff,
order, and so on.
After some time, I figured out
that the requirements are always the same, the
requirements that I just described,
and that at that point, maybe it's time
to have a unified solution, something that does
all this
in the way I would expect it.
I hope that it resonates with other people's
requirements and
feelings,
but, yeah, that's what we will discover after
some time.
First version was written in Python. Yeah. Actually,
the first version was Bash,
but then I turned to Python.
It was very specific to the projects that
I started to work on, that I worked
in the beginning,
mostly for my
customer and sponsor
this project. A big thanks to Helman, by
the way, if these people are listening.
And after some time, it got more generic
and was able to handle all kinds of
deployments.
It was not specific anymore to what they
did internally.
In the end, I decided to rewrite in
one so one
last time in Go
to actually have something
that integrates
very well into the Kubernetes ecosystem, which is
not so true with Python. I mean, it's
okay. You still have a lot of libraries
to work with the Kubernetes ecosystem, but it's
still better in Go.
Current status says version 2.15.
Next release is going to happen the next
days.
I personally
and my customers so far consider it stable
enough to be used in production.
So that's
about Are you going to do one more
last time rewrite and Rust?
Funny that that you say that. People have
actually tried to motivate me to do that.
I never looked into Rust. Not at all.
I'm pretty sure that it's
nice because that's what people tell me, but
let's put it this way. Rewriting it from
Python to Go was already a challenge,
and I'm happy with it right now. Awesome.
Sorry. I I won't distract you anymore. Carry
on, please. No. No. Do that. That's perfectly
fine.
So ClueScale tries to fulfill all the mentioned
requirements.
It does that by
have a natural and dynamic project structure. What
it means
will be I'll show it later when doing
the hands on. It's mostly decorative
but kind of imperative when needed. That means
we can still define the order.
We can deploy a namespace before actually deploying
objects into it. We can deploy CRDs before
actually deploying the CRs.
So many issues that I see with
customized or Helm or GitOps
can be solved
in that way by not being 100%
declarative.
It has native environments, so a first class
concept of environments. I call them targets
because after some time, I realized that
you don't only deploy
environments.
Sometimes you deploy stuff to a cluster, which
is, for example, base infrastructure stuff, and I
wouldn't call that an environment. It's the dev
cluster, but not the dev environment,
so I decided to call that concept targets.
Templating is possible everywhere,
absolutely everywhere.
There are one or two exceptions, but it's
really minimal.
This also includes helm values dot YAML, so
you don't have to write
five different helm values
files
for five different
environments. You can write one and use templating
to
actually do the one small change that is
required to make it work on prod and
test at the same time.
It offers a unified CLI.
That means whatever deployment you have at hand,
you always use it the same way. You
do a deploy for the target, so you
call Kluctl,
a Kluctl control,
deploy
-t and the target name. You do the
same with diff,
with delete, with prune and so on.
So that means if you know how to
use Kluctl, you know how to
deploy anything with that.
I reuse
Helm and customize as much as possible, and
they are actually customized
as the low level building block.
The most low level part is customized and
the resources
that customize customize
is customizing.
So let's stop with the presentation and actually
do the hands on. Let's do it.
Great.
Any
comments, questions before I start?
Nope. We just wanna see an action.
Sorry. Lost my voice there. Yeah. We just
wanna see an action then.
Great.
I have that.
Do you see that as well? I'm Presentation
mode just so that we can
Oh oh, yeah.
They need to move that thing away here.
So presentation mode.
Awesome. Thank you.
And I need to console.
Great.
So
first thing we, of course, need, as always,
with everything related to Kubernetes is Kubernetes cluster.
I decided to just use kind.
Let's start with a single kind cluster.
Theoretically,
I could create multiple kind clusters and then
show everything based on these two clusters. I'll
just use one for simplicity and instead,
let's say, deploy
multiple environments
just by changing namespaces.
I could also
do it with multiple clusters. Maybe we have
time later and we can actually show that.
So which targets can be deployed to. As
an example,
let's have one that we call dev.
I'll explain that in a second, and one
that is called prod.
If you have any wishes, just tell me.
Any additional targets or something like that?
So
I think name is obvious. It's the name
of the target. When I later call Kluctl
Kluctl control I
think I'll just say Kluctl from now on
because Yeah. Go first. It it seems to
be in my mind already.
So
whenever I call it, I'll give it the
name of the targets that I'm referring to,
which will be this one.
I'm But the context is just the kubectl
contact. Right? Exactly.
The idea is that the target itself is
bound to the context that you want to
deploy it to.
So you don't have to mess around with
your local
context. You don't have to set it before.
You don't have to ensure that you're in
the correct context.
The
target is bound to that one. You can
override it, but you normally wouldn't do that.
You can also work without the context here,
and then it will behave the same as
kubectl is, for example, working, just uses the
current active context.
I prefer to always explicitly set the context
because then it just it's just impossible to
deploy dev to prods by accident.
In this example, I'm using the same context
twice. We are deploying to the same cluster,
which is also fine because, I mean, there
might be a test cluster running two different
environments for testing purposes, or every developer has
its own environment and so on.
And in this case, just to showing it's
just using the same cluster.
So that's the targets.
I'm assuming you can enrich that with a
namespace somehow for prod?
Yeah. That's what I'm going to do in
the resources later through templating. Okay.
What I can do is let's do it
now. I can pass arguments
to targets.
For example,
let's call it arc one
and
give it this one. You could do whatever
you want here. Actually, this is plain YAML,
so I could also do
if it makes sense, I mean,
whatever.
At this point, you can do pass whatever
you want. I think those Rx can be
consumed in the template and language.
Sorry? I'm assuming those Rx can be used
within the templating.
Exactly. Okay. These Rx that you see that
you see see here are kind of the
entry point into the templating language.
It
is not supposed to, like, give this 10
pages of YAML here to configure your target.
Instead, you give it the actually, let's let's
do it different. Let's give an argument called
nth type and call it
non prod. I think that makes sense.
And one
so
we have
the argument end type, and we have two
flavors of it, non prod and prod. We
can give it whatever we want. It will
make sense later.
So the next thing that we need is
a deployment.
YAML.
This can get confusing. This is not a
Kubernetes deployment.
So it's not the kind deployment. It's a
Kluctl deployment.
And what it does is it defines
other deployments.
Let's start with a simple one,
namespaces.
So
this is a list of
deployment items.
An item can be or actually is always
a customized deployment.
So we
said we want to have namespaces.
This is,
as said,
customized.
Did I type it correctly?
I believe so. Yeah. This
is just customized. You can do always everything
that you can usually do in customize. You
can specify resources. You can use generators. You
can use patches,
whatever you need. Experience
shows that usually just resources is used.
Sometimes patches are used.
All the advanced features of customized, for example,
overlays and bases and so on,
you can use it, but at the point
where you start to use Kluctl,
you don't need it anymore.
So
you don't use it that often.
let's have a namespace YAML.
So why would you use a customization YAML
rather than just as a straight up Kubernetes
YAML? Like, if you're not using bases, you're
not using patches, would you not just have,
like, namespace dot YAML?
It's probably
just because of historical reasons. Because in the
beginning, this was just a wrap up for
for customize
Okay. And then got more and more and
more. I could implement that as an additional
feature to just not require the customization YAML.
Flux does something like that. If you specify
the customization
that does doesn't have a customization YAML, it
just treats all
YAMLs as customization resources by default.
I could do that as well.
Yeah. I
mean, one of my requirements was no boilerplate.
So, actually, I could apply that
same requirement here as well. Just
I'll open it, actually. Don't worry.
Perfect. That's what I want to see.
So we have namespace YAML.
Always struggle to remember simple stuff.
I think it's just Yep.
Kind namespace
metadata
names. Okay. Now it gets interesting.
So I could, of course, just have a
hard coded
name here,
but that's not fun. What we actually want
to do is,
let's say,
demo dash
and now
dot
oh, no. Actually,
dot name.
So
let me describe templating a little bit.
What you see here is Ginger templating. You
can use it everywhere.
There are one or two exceptions. I'm not
going to explain them.
But, usually,
whenever you see YAML, you can use gender
templating.
The templating context starts
with this as the entry point.
So you always have the target object.
The target has the name context.
This one is a little special. You can
just use args dot env type. You don't
have to type target dot args dot env
type.
So
as said, we have the target name, which
is set just by default, and we can
use it, for example, to have a dynamic
namespace name.
So everything
whatever
target we deploy, the name to this will
be named differently now.
And I think at this point, we are
done with the most basic deployment.
There's one thing
that I need to add. It's a requirement.
Let's go close it here.
IO slash,
I'll explain it in a second.
Just the requirements,
the the root deployment YAML. So we'll later
be more deployment YAML involved. The root deployment
YAML must list
a set of common labels,
which are applied to all Kubernetes resources. This
is later required to do deletion and pruning
of objects because Kluctl
must be able to
identify what belongs to the deployment so that
it can actually clean up and delete stuff.
So this is equivalent
or your alternative to having a state file
is to add labels to the resources. Exactly.
There is no state involved at all. So
I in the beginning, I was like, how
do I solve this? And I was thinking,
like, maybe I just write a conflict map
to to the cluster or something like that,
but then I decided just use labels
and force the user. And if I wouldn't
have specified that this, Kluctl would actually complain
that it's missing.
So
Could you not just do it by default?
I was considering that, but the problem is
sometimes
there it's possible to use in a to
use deployments without targets,
and then this would break if I add
some kind of default logic for that. I'm
still considering how to solve it.
Maybe I or someone comes up with with
a solution to that. But right now, it's
a requirement.
Okay. And I do complain complain to you
about that.
So we now have a basic deployment.
So let's do some Kluctl stuff.
First thing yeah. Let's just do a deployment.
Let's deploy that first.
So as I explained
I didn't really explain, but just I I
mentioned it. If you do a deployment, what
it will do is it will first do
a dry run and then print a diff.
Then it asks you if that's fine for
you. You say yes or no. If you
say yes, it will actually apply it.
If you say no, just nothing else.
In this case, it just tells you there's
a new object, and that's it. It's what
we would have expected. And that's it. We
have a
namespace deployed
right now.
Let me
figure out how to
actually prove that something has happened.
I hope everyone knows k nine s. Yeah.
Can you It's not increase the font size
quite a bit. It's very small.
You should tell me how to do that.
Command plus.
Command plus. Yep. That looks good.
Two more. Is that okay?
One more?
There we go. That'll do. Thank you. Okay.
Great.
So what you should see now is the
namespace.
Demo dev. Great. So we see the templating
value has been replaced. Great.
I think it's clear oops. This is not
what I wanted to do.
I think it's clear that I can now
also do
This is the wrong
Yes. Intelligence. This
is Kluctl itself.
I have too much stuff.
I think it's pretty clear. I can also
do a deployment to prod now, which is
the same
cluster but a different namespace,
and it's the same thing.
And we should now be able to see
yep. There it is. And new namespace.
Can I suggest some changes just because I
am curious now?
Can
I suggest the next step?
Sure.
I think the next step is to first
close first. Close that one.
Yeah.
Where's close? Just
Just The red button. Other. So I go
this one
and then file close
other projects. That's what I want. Okay. And
then namespace dot YAML.
Here as well? Or
Yeah. There.
Oh, yeah. Can we add
a label?
Sure.
I wanna see how
rich the deaf information gets. So just call
this name Rawkode. No. You can't call it
name. Just something Rawkode, a b c colon
Rawkode or something like that. And then do
the deploy to dev again. I'm curious.
We've seen new objects on the deploy, but
it does the dev give us more rich
information as well?
Yes.
It will give you a diff, and it
will not give you a unified diff.
Very at least for me, it's very important.
Unified diff is a nice thing if you
want to diff text.
If you are diffing
structured stuff, for example, YAML or JSON, you
really don't want to see unified diff.
What you want to see is what has
actually structurally or logically changed. So you want
to see the path and then the change
inside that. In this case, it's easy. We
edit.
It's this
it's a JSON path. We edit
the string. Okay. Can you apply that? And
then we'll make one more change just because
I I always need to kinda see what
happens. But let's change Rawkode to have two
hours, like, a simple table, you know, and
then run that again.
Awesome.
I like this. And
it will show you this table for every
object where it detects changes.
So in the end, let's even if you
have hundreds of objects, you are able to
scroll through it and at least do some
kind of pattern matching.
Or if it's just a few objects, really
go into detail and figure out what has
changed.
Yeah. This is something that I would find
important in the pull request process. Like, I
I I just wanna see this step as
a comment on my GitHub or something and
just say, hey. This is what's about to
go to your environment. So yeah. Thanks. This
is something I'm working on right now, actually,
to
have some
so maybe
another topic.
I'm
there's also a GitOps
based controller, the Flux Clue Cuddle controller,
which is doing GitOps style deployments
for all the stuff. And I'm also working
on another controller, which is not done yet.
So it's it's not completely public yet, which
will allow to
kind of connect your deployments
to pull requests
to whatever you like. And it will do
that. It will show you this. It will
tell you if stuff
is
actually running and ready and so on.
It will approve for you or unapproved and
so on. K. We have a a question
in the comments as well from Google who
wants to know whether we can now revert
this with
Kluctl.
So can we uninstall production?
Uninstall production. Yeah. Sure. We can delete it.
It will it's the same here. It will
first tell me what it's going to do.
It will delete this namespace.
And now we see wait. Did I do
prod? You said dev. Yeah.
You see? Luckily, we have a diff, and
luckily, we actually looked at it. So you
want to delete prod.
And then it tells you to delete demo
prod. And that's it. Thank you. There you
go, Hugo. You can easily revert with Kluctl.
I guess I I don't depending on what
Hugo was specifically asking,
I guess, the the change be could I
revert the previous change? Yeah. I mean, that
would be a asking about
that. That would be a git operation. Alright?
That would be a a git reset and
then
Yeah. If if you do if you do
GitOps and or any other type of continuous
deployment, then, yes, you would do it through
Git. Just revert the change and
let whatever needs to happen happen.
If you are just working from your local
machine, then you would just do the change
and deploy it and see in the diff
if it's what you actually want to do.
Yeah. I guess because this is a entirely
stateless application,
there there's no rollbacks like we would see
with Helm. Right? So you use the ability
to do that. Exactly.
Even the Helm integrations that I
implemented,
which I'm going to show later,
does not
use
full Helm
style
installations,
so you cannot roll them back because I'm
fully deep
fully relying on on Git at that point.
So if you want to revert something, revert
it in Git and do a fresh deployment.
Alright. That helps, Jacob. Thank you.
Cool.
Maybe
yeah. I'll I'll show that later. So we
have that one now. Let's
this is an an interesting point now.
We always had this problem,
and me as well, so
you did something. You deployed a lot of
stuff to devs, then you did something on
prod, and you switched around. And then you're
at the point like, oh, did I actually
deploy that already to
this environment? And I'm at that point right
now. I don't even I I completely forgot
what the state of dev is.
And I can just do a deploy, and
now I see, oh, it's actually fine. I
already deployed everything,
which is a good feeling to to trust
the tooling and the deployment itself.
I hope I made my point little Okay.
What to show next?
Now we're at the point where we actually
want to deploy something.
I'm completely open to what to deploy. Usually,
I just deploy pod info or something like
that. If you have any idea for something
that is not too complex, that doesn't need
too much configuration,
that would usually work with a simple helm
install,
just tell me, and we use it as
an example.
So you're looking for
a helm resource?
Yeah. We can we can start with a
Helm
or some plain
resources.
Okay. Let's just do a standard deployment that
deploys PodM for NGINX. Either or is fine.
Okay. It's through Helm or it's through plain
YAML? Plain YAML. I mean Okay. Is there
anything else you want to show in plain
YAML that's different from the namespace example? Yeah.
Maybe, yeah, maybe it's easier to just show
it based on that and later go into
to Helm.
So
let's do
pod info.
Create a folder.
We go to the root deployment again,
and we just add
in as
deployment here, so now what I explained in
regard to declarative and ordering and stuff like
that. So
by default, what Clue CDL does is everything
that is listed here is deployed in parallel,
so it doesn't care about ordering.
But if you realize
ordering is important, and in this case, it
definitely is important because you cannot deploy port
info into the namespace because namespace is available,
what you can do is you can
add a barrier
in between,
which means do everything that is before this
barrier in parallel,
then wait till it's finished. Finished means it's
applied. It doesn't mean it's ready. It just
means it's applied for a namespace that's enough.
And then continue with all the stuff following
in parallel again.
So it's super fast,
but
takes into account ordering whenever needed. That's what
I tried to explain with the declarative versus
imperative stuff.
It is the same with CRDs. So if,
for example, you're deploying the sealed secrets controller,
you know it's going to deploy CRDs,
and you cannot deploy sealed secrets before you
have deployed the sealed secrets controller. So it
you would add the sealed secrets controller here
at a barrier, and then you would deploy
the sealed secrets.
Okay.
So put info.
So we have a
I called k eight s deployment right now
because it might otherwise get confusing with c
deployment demos.
I
cannot remember
what deployment looks like. I always had to
copy paste. App slash v one.
No. I I really don't want to type
out the full d engine next deployment now
or put in for deployments.
I've got it all done by heart. Like,
that's how that's the only flex I've got.
Sorry. I didn't get it done. It's alright.
I've just been silly. Okay. Please feel free
to copy and paste the deployment.
Yeah.
Should have prepared one.
There is one.
The yes. In the comments, I was looking
forward to seeing the helm.
So we'll get to that in just a
minute.
Yeah. I'll I'll try to speed up with
this one. So
I found an engine x deployment that's
so
do you know if pod in pod in
was available as a hand chart. Right? So
maybe we do it the other way around.
We start with NGINX.
So just using this deployment. I'm not going
to add a service now. I'm not going
to add ingresses and stuff like that. We
we're just going to ignore that.
But we need to do a few things.
We, of course, have to deploy to to
the correct namespace
because otherwise, it would be default.
How did we call it? Demo dash
targets Target dot name. Yep. Yeah.
Let's start with one replica. Everything else should
be fine. I'm not going to do any
configuration or stuff like that. I don't even
know what it will show if nothing is
deployed, maybe some hello or something like that,
but that's fine.
So we need a customization again. Doing some
copy paste now.
And I think we are done.
This should be the basic
yeah. NGINX deployment. Let's deploy it,
and it's done.
And
in k nine s, we should see
it's starting up now.
Pulling image,
and it's running. So I said I'm not
going to deploy services ingresses,
nothing like that. I'm just using the port
forwarding feature of k nine s. I said,
doesn't know k nine s? Really, you have
to get to know it because it's just
great.
So we have local host.
Come on. Host.
Eighty eighty.
And we have NGINX running. That's great.
Okay. I think that one was quite easy.
Maybe before
I start with the Helm part, I do
some
some more in regard to
configuration
and templating.
The deployment YAML also defines which variables are
available inside the templating context.
It's done by the vars key,
and it's a list of vars sources.
One of them is the file,
and it's arbitrary what I put in here.
So it it the only requirement is that
it's part of the
project that I'm in right now. So
let's
say inside vast, we have
a common dot YAML.
So we actually need that folder.
Oops. Vars.
Common dot YAML.
Any ideas for for Vars?
Let's say replicas.
Yeah. Let's
let's do that later.
So let's make the end of next version
configurable.
Very important. This is plain
YAML. So I could actually do something like
that because maybe it's
easier to maintain later.
I can do whatever I want here. Lists,
dictionaries, everything.
And I think that's obvious as well now.
So that's it.
So to explain it again, inside the root
deployment YAML, we include the vast file common
YAML.
It defines NGINX
version,
and then we can use it everywhere
that is included from here. Do you really
consume it as NGINX.version
instead of vars.NGINX.version?
Yeah. It's really NGINX.version.
So what if I my common dot YAML
have target colon name?
I think you can actually do that, and
it will override your target name. If you
do that,
bad idea. I'm not sure if I wouldn't
if I if I would try to
to stop you from doing that. Ideas is
my middle name, I'm afraid. I always try
to think of how I could break something.
So
Yeah. I mean, it's your it's your right
to do that. I mean, I I think
I know what what what you're up to.
Yeah. I I expected there to be a
prefix, like target Yeah. And args and then
and then bars. But Yeah. Makes sense, actually.
Maybe that's also something I should consider.
Yeah. I'll I'll think about that. And you
can, of course, do a Got an issue.
Great.
There there's one thing where it is already
implemented this way. So everything that you pass
through arcs inside the
target definition
is available through arcs dot.
So for example, I could use n type
here. Doesn't make sense, of course, but just
to show it.
I'll show why the axe are so so
nice later a little bit.
So we have the engine x version here.
Let's do a deploy. Nothing should change because
we haven't actually changed anything. We just did
some refactoring right now.
That's also what I explained before.
I always want to know if my change
has the
expected consequences.
In this case, it shouldn't have any consequences,
and this verifies that it's the case.
Let's say if I change this to dot
one, I should see it in the diff.
So there we see it again. As said,
it shows here the JSON path to the
point where it's changed, and then it shows
this unified diff,
which is a very short one. Can you
open the case deployment dot YAML, please?
Yes.
Can you remove the namespace from the top?
Mhmm.
And then run
deploy again?
It's actually a good idea.
Let's do a little bit different thing. I'm
going to deploy that to prod now. Okay?
It doesn't make sense, but who cares? So
I think this is what what
you're retargeting, that it's going to the default
namespace right now. Let's assume we did that
by mistake. We completely forgot that we had
to actually set the namespace,
and we deployed it to prod.
Now we realize, oh, what
have we done? We deployed something to the
wrong namespace,
and we have to fix it. Now, the
naive solution is to just add the namespace
and assume that this has fixed it. But
if you deploy that,
it doesn't
just change the namespace. It actually means I'm
deploying a second version of that same deployment
to another namespace because the old one is
still there.
I think that's what you were Yeah. I
wanted to see how it how it identifies
the replace.
Yeah.
So what it will show you now
wait. This is something it's in my head
which needs to be changed.
So let's do diff. A diff will basically
just show show you that and show you
often object as well.
So it tells you what you actually do
right now is you create a new deployment,
and then there is an often object which
I don't recognize anymore, but it looks like
it was part of my deployment
in the past.
What you can do now is you can
deploy it first.
In this case, you just see new deployments.
It doesn't show you that they are also
orphan object.
After deployment, it would show you the orphan
objects. So this is something I need to
change to actually show that before as well.
So what we have now is we have
that same deployment two times, once in the
correct namespace, once in the wrong namespace.
If your tooling doesn't support you properly,
you might end up with garbage
all over your cluster because of such things
happening,
and you wouldn't realize it.
With GitOps,
you can do prune.
You can enable pruning for your deployments and
it will handle it. But if you're
not using it, you end up with completely
Okay. Before you prune that, can you go
back to k nines?
Something's odd. Right? Is that
replica set ID is the same on both.
How did that happen?
Replica is what? One?
No. The replica set. The can you run
look at replica sets and k nines across
all namespaces.
Seven five six five eight d four seven
seven seven and two namespaces.
That's pretty Oh,
this is really strange.
No. I know what you mean.
This is strange. It is strange.
Must be something that must be something to
do with the deterministic nature of the replicas
that Yeah. Are created across
that's I've I've never seen that before. I'm
gonna have to dig in. Yeah. I actually
never looked into at that point, but you're
right. It's interesting.
So there must be some deterministic way to
to figure out the names that it uses
internally.
Yeah. Based on maybe the revision ID, the
generation,
and the the hash of the object. Yes.
Which means you could probably do some
this is not And I sort of clustered,
but I'm never working out ways that I
can do collisions
across clusters. But that that's the Yeah. But
but I assume it's still fine at least
in inside the same cluster because it's still
namespace.
It's still in different namespace.
But, yeah, let's get back to
okay. So here we have c parts. So
you, of course, don't want to have that
garbage on your cluster, and you want to
clean up immediately when you realize that situation.
What you can do this Kluctl is just
to prune,
and it will delete the objects that it
determined as often.
Okay. So We have a
in the chat from Matthias. Mhmm.
And it's something I was thinking too, but
they were I'm assuming they maybe are familiar
with the tool, but they're asking if there's
an override namespace in the deployment dot YAML,
which is, I think, a good question because
I would probably forget to specify the namespace
and a resource at some point. So can
that I
Yeah. I I think
that's Matthias.
I I think I know him. And, yeah,
he's quite familiar with it. I think what
he wants to ask is
so as we're using customize, we could, of
course, also say that we
tell it to use this namespace at this
point. Mhmm. So this is one option to
avoid such situations, just using customize
to set the namespace.
I think it's clear what what I'm going
to do here.
Right?
Demo and so on.
I'm not going to do that now for
for the demo purposes.
Another option is inside the deployment YAML
to also say
override
namespace
and basically do the same.
So demo
target dot name. It would have the same
it and not not not exactly.
So what override namespace does is every customize
that it encounters that doesn't have a namespace
set will get that namespace.
So if a customization
still says I want to deploy it to
Bloop,
it will still be deployed to Bloop because
override is only happening
if it's not set.
But I'm not
I I'll not go into more detail in
in in that regard if that's fine for
you.
Okay.
Okay. Where did I stop? So
I think we were yeah. We we were
here with.
So I included a common YAML. That's not
very interesting.
It's nice, but it's
not the most important thing.
You
remember that I said that the arcs from
the target are more like an entry point
to the configuration.
Because if you would write down all the
configuration that is required for one environment, it's
easy to end up with pages of just
YAML inside this YAML,
which would make it hard to maintain.
So instead,
I tend to use it just as an
entry point. For example, env type, there's prod
and
non prod.
And what I can do inside the deployment
YAML then is, as I said, templating is
possible nearly everywhere.
I can use that to define which file
to include.
So what we can do now is
have a prod dot YAML
and have a non prod dot YAML.
What you can do now is
again, this is arbitrary YAML,
and what you can do now is
have the same stuff here.
And, for example, say, replicas
for non prod, let's have one.
For prod, let's have three.
Is it clear what this does? It is.
Yeah.
Great.
One thing that I should also mention is
this is layered on top.
This means first, this one is loaded,
then the
template context is enhanced,
then this one is loaded,
having this
included as well already. So I could theoretically
use
engine x dot version
here already. It doesn't make sense right now,
but I could do it. So I can
layer
one
on another and
kind of
do all kind of fancy stuff with that.
Then another thing is
if
one
vast file
has the same defined as
the one above, for example, we have
replicas here,
it will overwrite this one value.
So it does a,
yeah, a merge of of the YAML files.
So what you can also do is, let's
say,
we don't define anything for non prod.
So the default is to have replicas one.
But for prod, we have some special configuration
which say which says overwrite this value with
three.
Is that clear so far? It is.
Great.
And I think it's obvious. We just use
that value here.
And let's
do a dev deployment first because
nothing happens, which is expected because we didn't
change the replicas.
Right? Mhmm. But I completely forgot that it's
actually expected to nothing,
to to change nothing, but luckily, my tooling
is helping.
For prod, it should look different,
and something is wrong.
Because you did a print.
Oh, yeah.
That's what happens if you you see it's
really too much.
So and it
tells us that there is actually a change
for prod.
And we say yes,
and we see
more replicas,
which we expected. Great.
I assume that this feature we see is
I think it's clear. Right? It is.
Very important.
This is a list of vast sources. File
is just one type of vast source. There
are other types. For example,
HTTP.
You can do an HTTP request and load
some YAML from from the web.
You can load something
from
some
GitLab repo.
Does that work for deployments too instead of
path?
Yes.
Awesome.
Okay. Say git include, but I'm not going
to show that now because
that's what require gits to be set up
with and stuff like that.
So you then also give it the easy
path and so on.
What else?
Vault.
Vault is experimental.
We have HWS secrets manager.
And what else?
Cluster
config maps. This is also very interesting.
I think it's namespace,
name and key.
I don't remember exactly which ones need to
be specified, but what you can also do
is while you're deploying, it's loading something from
the cluster using that as variable source, and
then you can use it in the templating.
Yeah. That's just bit more interesting for me
in a personal level. I
I do a lot of
conference talks. And one of the ones I've
been given a lot over the last two
years is to talk about get ups and
how Mhmm. Actually, overlays are an anti pattern
because we encode environmental information into our application
deployment description
when really our application shouldn't actually know the
environment exists. The environment should provide everything that
needs. And with this cluster config map option,
we actually provide a way to say,
here's enough information to deploy and get everything
else from the cluster itself. Like, that to
me is a killer feature. Yep. It is.
We use it as an example to provide
so so what we do is we have
a kind of cluster based deployment,
which is a Kluctl
deployment,
which contains ingress controllers,
gatekeeper,
Selium is deployed in. Like, everything you need
to have a usable cluster. So you start
with a naked cluster and you provide it
with everything that you need. What we also
deploy as part of that is oh, no.
Actually, one step before when we create the
naked cluster through cluster RP, we also
deploy a config map containing information about the
low level infrastructure, for example, networking, which subnets
are used for the cluster and stuff like
that. So it's just a config map. Every
cluster has that.
In the end,
the base deployment can then use cluster config
map to load that config map, then get
information about the subnets,
which is usually a mess to get from
Terraform into
your deployments and stuff like that. So
in this way, it's it's
quite easy. And then we can use that
information to configure Cilium properly to use the
correct subnets
and so on. I I think you understand
this. You can
do a lot of stuff with that.
There's also the the cluster secret, which is
basically the same. Just just the secrets.
Okay.
We've got just over twenty minutes left, so
I think we should get onto the helm
stuff and show that. Oh, yeah. Okay. Then
so I think we
described everything related to that. Okay. So
let's do something different. This is very important.
I'm not going to directly include the Helm
file. I'm going to
add a sub deployment,
which just contains
a deployment dot YAML,
which is the same as this one from
the ID. And what you do here now
is instead of pass, we say include
third party,
and
this one starts with deployments again.
And here, we have, again, a customized deployment,
and we call it pod info. I know
it's Helm,
internally,
customize is used to actually deploy Helm.
It will get clearer in a few minutes.
So we have the pod info.
And now
we have the customization
YAML
resources.
Ignore that for now. I'm going to explain
it in a minute. So now the HAM
integration. Now it gets interesting. So for the
HAM integration, we first specify
which HAM chart we actually want to pull
in.
I keep forgetting
the format
of that. Let me do a copy paste.
So there's documentation at Kluctl.io.
I hope I have documented everything that is
needed.
If something is missing, just tell me, and
I'll provide it.
And I'm copying
from there right now. So
this is the basic structure of the Helm
chart. As you maybe already see, it's just
a representation of what you would usually give
Helm while you install something.
You give it to repo, chart name, chart
version, and so on.
Dot.
So
let me look for pod info.
There is the pod info chart. I know
you cannot see what I'm doing right now.
I'm on another screen.
Just doing some copy paste. So we specify
the repository.
We specify
the chart name, pod info, and we specify
the version,
six dot 2 dot one.
Just for demo purposes,
let's not use the latest one so that
we can later show how an update is
actually working. We don't want to skip updates.
We are happy with updates here.
Release name, it's the same as if you
would do a helm install.
Let's call it pod info
namespace.
Let's not forget it this time.
What was it? Target dot name demo dash
target dot name.
Just one output.
So
what it internally does is it renders the
Helm chart through the Helm template functionality.
And then it uses the resulting YAML
to write it into some internally temporary file
called deploy YAML,
and then use customize to actually load the
temporary file.
At that point, we can use customize, for
example, to even patch the HAM chart, which
is needed more often than I like,
for example, to add port security context and
stuff like that, which the HAM chart doesn't
support natively.
So
I think that's it for now.
I think I mentioned in the beginning that
for the Helm integration,
I do pre pulling.
That means before I can actually use that,
I have to pre pull that Helm chart
and put it into my version control.
I can do that by using Kluctl
helm pull. It will go through the project
and find all helm chart YAMLs
and pulling it and just putting it
near that hand chart YAML. This is really
just a copy of the chart itself.
It means I can also look into the
values YAML, for example, to figure out which
values are supported.
So I don't even have to go to
the to the website and read documentation.
The next step is we need helm values.
Not always, but
sometimes or actually in most cases,
which is the helm values.
And what you can do now, let let's
figure out what you can modify. We can
modify your replica count. That's interesting. So let's
say replica count.
As we are running out of time, I'm
just going to reuse the NGINX replicas now.
It's not correct. Of course, you wouldn't do
that in a real project, but for the
demo, it's good enough.
I think we are done.
We right now have a hand chart integrated,
and we should be able to
deploy it
right now.
Unknown shorthand. What?
You forgot dash t. Yeah.
And what you see is yeah.
Yeah. This is the change that I didn't
deploy.
And you see a list of new objects,
deployment pod info and service pod info.
Going to deploy that now.
And
k nine s. Yep. Looks good.
Thread.
We assume that's normal in the beginning. Yeah.
Logs look good. Let's do some port forwarding.
9898.
9 8 9 8.
And there we have bot info. You can
do stuff here. Nice.
So that's the basic HAM integration.
Any questions at that point? Any comments?
No. That makes that makes sense. Like, our
intermediate deploy dot YAML, I guess that's cleaned
up by Kluctl.
Cleaned up? Well, I don't see it.
Yeah. It's it's not not happening in this
folder because I'm
Okay. Too scared to destroy something important. What
I'm doing is I'm
creating a temporary folder, and then I'm rendering
the complete project into that temporary folder.
And as part of that rendering process, I
also create the templates from the hand charts
and put the temporary files into that temporary
folder so I do not mess with the
actual project,
which would be scary.
Cool. So
I think that's clear. And now
I did a
small mention in in the in the
the slides that even the helm values are
templatable now. That means
I can do stuff like, let's say, in
the VARs for prods.
Let's say in in non prod, we have
prod info,
change color,
true.
Oh, no. Let's say false.
And for prod, we say change color,
shoe.
As said, arbitrary YAML, I could do whatever
I want here. In this case, I'm having
a Boolean.
And what I can do now is in
the helm values,
ginger templating,
if how do you call it? Pod info
dot change
color.
I can do some conditional stuff here.
Yeah. Don't don't be confused about the errors
that it's showing because Ginger and YAML and
IDEs,
lots of good friends.
So inside the pod info, where you see
them, I've seen that you can specify color.
That's all.
Let's do
think it should support something like this. This
is well.
And
done.
So the interesting thing is we know that
we have changed some helm values, but in
the end, we have no idea what that
actually means.
Because depending on how the templates are implemented,
this could mean everything.
And we don't know before it's deployed usually.
But with ClusterityO, what we see now is
we see a full diff which says nothing
has changed
because for dev, change color is false.
This is a bad example now, as I
realized, because we wouldn't see a diff
on prods. Sorry?
Just swap prod and non prod around to
true and the false. Yeah. Yeah. That's Keep
it simple.
Exactly.
So
doing it again, we should see the detailed
diff about what actually happened. For example,
it didn't just change some value, it also
added something to the deployment, which wasn't there
before. And now I see that this actually
had that consequence.
And I can either say yes or no,
and I'm fine with that change. I don't
know if this green stuff really works, but
I assume yes.
So
after some time,
looks like it's already restarted.
The port forwarding
has to be reset.
And it's green.
Great.
But only on that.
So can we do the Helm upgrade to
six one one as well?
Yeah.
So, usually, you would have all this in
Git
because
everyone uses Git. So let's create a Git
project first. I wouldn't it's not really required.
I could show everything just without Git, but
I'd like to show the Git integration as
well when it comes to Helm upgrades.
I'm doing something that I really hate, and
if I ever see anyone doing that,
I'll scream at him.
What
is it?
Oh my god.
What is happening here?
It's get add dot and then get commit
dash m.
Okay. Get add dot. Yep. And then you
can do get commit with a message.
Yeah.
Well, what I'm trying to say is never
add everything and commit it just without verifying
what you actually committed, but that's a different
story.
So we have
a simple
git repository now with just one commit.
And what we want to do now is
we want to figure out for the dozens
of ham charts that we are using. We
probably already forgot which ones we are using
because it's just so many.
We want to just upgrade everyone. Actually, let's
just figure out which ones have upgrades.
I forgot to tell. Update or upgrade. Help
update.
And it tells me, oh, there's a ham
chart. It has a new version available,
and I could upgrade.
If I decide I actually want to upgrade,
what I can do is tell it to
upgrade.
This will do the upgrade and write the
changes to the local file files,
but that's not enough. I actually want to
have it committed as well.
So it
updated it, pulled it, committed it. So if
you look into the, oops,
into the logs, we see a commit
that has only
the specific changes related to that update included.
So even if I would have pending changes
anywhere else, this commit would be a clean
commit just containing the
the update. And do you get one that
per Helm chart, or is it all grouped
together? It's one per Helm chart. The idea
is that if you realize, okay,
it's nice to upgrade pod info, but upgrading
Selium is maybe
bad idea right now. You can
revert that one commit, for example,
or just rebase and remove that one commit
or whatever you want. So you can use
Git's features to
to manage your your Helm upgrades.
So
inside the diff of that one
k. What?
You can then see, oh, okay. The app
version has changed.
Usually, you would use
magic quest or something like that and have
a nice view of what we see here
right now. But as said, you can do
a source level
review
and verify that what happens is really what
you want to happen. And then the next
step is, of course, because as said,
in the end,
it might be that there are hundreds of
lines changed, but it's not affecting your deployment
at all or just changing the image version,
for example.
So the final step is to actually look
at the diff because this is the truth.
This is what's actually going to happen. What
you see here is now the label's being
changed. Makes sense. Version information. Version information. The
image has changed
and nothing else. That looks like a
easy upgrade that we just accept,
and we are done.
So that's the Helm integration. I've been quite
fast now. How does that work with Helm
hooks? Are those supported?
Yeah. Sure.
Is there an example of Helm Hooks?
Yeah. I'm I'm not sure if I'm able
to find that. I'm not sure if the
Hooks work with Helm template. So I'm assuming
maybe we lose access to them.
No. No. It's so Helm template just
just
writes out the same YAMLs. It doesn't care
about its if it's a hook or not.
Kluctl knows about Helm hooks, and it knows
how to handle them. It knows
when to deploy them, when to delete them,
it knows when to wait for them. It
kind of replicates the behavior that Helm does.
At the same time, it allows you to
have own hooks,
so you don't have to write Helm chart
just to have hooks.
If you need
to do something
I'm not able to come up with something
on the fly right now. No. That's okay.
You would just add
annotations.
Kluctl.io.
Hook.
So it's
so you have Kluctl specific hooks,
which are mostly like what you know from
Helm.
They are just named a little bit different
because in
in Kluctl,
we don't do installs. We do deploys. So
it's
all called a little bit differently.
But if it encounters
a Helm
hook,
it would just work as if it has
had been from a from a Helm Okay.
Chart. Nice.
So that's it.
And there are other annotations that change how
stuff is handled.
Example, conflict resolution is very important. There are
cases, for example, the Elastic
operator, the Elastic Cloud operator,
tends to take over ownership
of fields that it shouldn't touch.
For example, the node specs. And in the
end,
the
managed fields
tell you that you lost ownership of that.
And you can tell Kluctl to
kind of force apply
whenever that happens
and to take back ownership of something that
you know is yours and no one else
should touch it.
So you have stuff like Kluctlestar.io,
force, apply, and set it to true. Must
be string because it's an invitation.
And so there are many other things that
you can use to
control the behavior of your deployments.
You can even do stuff like Clue CDL
.I o delete
true.
It's funny because
you are deploying something, but you're actually deleting
something. So what it will do is it
will ignore everything. So it will ignore the
complete spec.
And whenever it encounters delete true, just delete
that object.
This is
sounds funny because
it's maybe hard to understand why that is
needed.
One example is if you deploy to a
fresh Kubernetes
EKS cluster from AWS,
you have a daemon set running there that
provides the AWS
any
CNI.
So the low level CNI that's HWS specific.
If you want to use Selium, you don't
want to have that daemon set running there.
It must be deleted, actually. And to avoid
having
manual steps
to deploy Selium, you can instead have a
dummy daemon set that has Kluctl delete set
to true, and then that object is going
to be deleted.
You can also do that as part of
the deployment YAML. So you can
and then it's forgot how to so you
specify
how to identify it and name, so it's
name, and so on. And so it knows
that at that point, it should just delete
that object.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright. We have five minutes left. That's our
Yeah. Issue you wanna cover, or should we
jump back to back face mode and just
chat for a few minute?
It depends. If you have any ideas, any
questions where you think it should be shown,
just
say it. If not, we can just go
to the face to face mode again.
Yeah. Let's jump back. Because we have you've
you you've covered a lot there.
I can cover a lot more if you
want.
It's
when deploying
to Kubernetes is a complex topic.
That's a fact. It is. What I what
I loved is every time I saw, oh,
how would I handle this use case or
how would I handle this? It's like there
was there was a way
to modify and change that behavior. Even down
to that last example there where we have
either the ability to apply
dummy resource with the the delete annotation, but
even in the deployment spec just to have
to delete objects Yeah. As well. So, like,
there's
yeah.
I'm pretty sure this could probably handle any
complex deployment that I was gonna throw at
it, which is quite exciting. So
Yeah. We have very complex deployments,
and we actually deploy
everything with it right now. One question in
between. Am I still sharing, or are we
in face to face mode? Still face mode.
K. Then let me open.
Where is it?
So that I can see you as well.
So no. Okay. I can see you as
well. Great. So
what was the question? Sorry.
I there there wasn't a question. I was
just really happy that, you know, I was
in my head as we were walking through,
you know, I wonder how I'd handle this
situation. You know, the EKS one is a
big one. Like, EKS ships with a bunch
of default resources by default. You either need
to modify or delete or replace and the
hooks are there to do that.
If you're working with Helm charts, you've got
the ability to template the YAML. The values
failed, but not even just that. It supports
all the hooks. And then,
Kluctl has its own hooks. So if I
need to do more things, then I have
access to that. Like, it's a really powerful
tool
and something I think I'm definitely gonna have
to experiment with. And, you know, I always
say my production, but it's like my production,
you know, it's my cluster that I do
on my YouTube automation on, you know, my
website automation
So,
yeah, this is a really, really cool tool.
And I can see from all of those
features that you've added to you must have
been working on this for quite a long
time.
Yes. As I said, it had multiple incarnations,
so it was not immediately in that state.
For me, it's very important to reduce the
set of features
to a minimum and not have specific features.
Like, in the past, there was a lot
of stuff to handle environments correctly, and then
I realized I can't do all this with
templating.
So I removed a lot of features and
just stick to the to the base features.
I mean, it's still a lot, but
yeah.
Trying to I think I personally I don't
think I would use.
I only have one target, and I would
use that config map from cluster
to do all the environment enrichment.
That's that's the thing that I'm most excited
to experiment with as I start to play
with quick control. So You can you can
mix that. For example, you could decide to
use targets
just for to targeting a cluster
and then hand over to the config map
to get in the actual configuration. So you
have But if I use it as a
get up style environment, I don't really need
the target. Right?
Yeah. And long term so and the I'm
working on that right now. The next release
c two dot 16 will actually improve sets
that you can do targetless
deployments,
which will then kind of behave like Kube
Kuttle would do, deploy those current
context.
And
Yeah. Yeah. To me, that that that's a
really interesting paradigm because it removes more boilerplate.
It moves more logic into the cluster,
and it simplifies
the deployment
manifest from the developer point of view. It's
like the environment will decide how many replicas
or how the HP should function or what
the angers domain names are. The developers
really shouldn't have any control over that because
they're not the ones responsible
for providing the environment in which the application
run.
And I think
Kluctl I mean, I've tried to do this
with Pulumi and CDK, but what I'm seeing
from Kluctl gives me
a simpler declaration and that I'm just working
with YAML, customizing helm tools that are almost
ubiquitous to this point, but I'm able to
enrich them with the behavior that I need
with the templating. And I think that's really
interesting. So I'm definitely gonna be kicking the
tires on it, so please expect a lot
of issues on the GitHub with that. Please.
Please. I've fumbled my way through it, and
maybe I'll just have to reach out, but
I need some help. And maybe we need
a second stream to cover all the other
features that we haven't even covered today. So
Yep. I can do that.
The good thing is, I mean, it the
project I'm working on it still
since quite some time, but I'm
I've not been publicly active
in the beginning. So that's what I started
the last few weeks or months.
That means user base is still, let's say,
growing.
The advantage of that is
that if you have feature requests or whatever,
it's right now, it's still easy to get
me
and to
to get me actually helping you immediately.
Well, yeah, there people can go to the
GitHub page where you can file issues.
You are also in the Rawkode Academy Discord.
So if people want more real time communication,
I'm sure you'd be okay. I hope I'm
just gonna assume you don't mind people tagging
me. And maybe we'll even create a channel
for quick control there just so that people
do wanna chat and I'm really seeing fashion.
It is available.
But I've been really impressed with what I've
seen. So I'll say thank you for for
working on this. I think it's a really
interesting project.
I'd like I said, definitely gonna try and
kick the tires on this for my production
infrastructure, and maybe I'll even submit a pull
request. We'll see.
Happy to hear that, and thanks for having
me. Alright. Well, it's been a pleasure, Alexander.
Thank you again. Thank you to the people
watching at home or watching after the fact
via the power of YouTube.
We'll keep you updated on my adoption of
Kluctl, and we'll be back again in the
future. Thanks a lot, and I'll see you
again soon. Bye bye.